I was on your show last week and Dennis
Prager was on who the
conservative radio host who I don't
agree with especially on the social
stuff
and you've been a big supporter a bill
GBT the gay community
and I could see you were getting into it
a little bit with him but with
it was based in respect and I'm sure
this program for years and I like him
now I don't agree with them I think that
the gay issue he is way off track but
becomes
from religious bent let me ask the
question
that court because you think that one
one thing I like
I like about questions the court when
Dennis Prager said
if you had to people you know the judge
someone's gonna get this child in
a gay couple or at a central couple and
their
equally valued who would you give the
job to
and I think the crowd as you might give
it a gay couple you what would have been
a
but I can see where he's coming from
where you can make a case
for that and I like great moral
arguments like that when the Sun was
presented to me
because it causes what we want to do is
think we want to progress we want to
thank
a written article the other day should
we be mad
at woody allen should we not see a Woody
Allen movie
because of what he did with supposedly
his young son
should we not so big question was posed
this way
and I love this suppose I showed you a
great painting
and you loved it what up painting
it captured drama Beneteau to Hitler
painted
with your opinion of the painting change
he probably would
why I guess that wouldn't be in the most
purest our descent overplayed it knowing
where it came from can you separate the
art
from the our daughters but those a great
moral questions we asked them all the
time
that's the kind of thing II that's a
kinda give-and-take
where you could have a guest I who may
not want to buy the painting
but the guest could defend get by a
painting Mon its value at its core
yeah right and that's does a great
arguments but you don't see any more
so speaking up that do you see the the
gay the movement as
sure the civil rights idea I know the
part time however I went through a lot
of things
no with you been a business 57 is I was
in miami
when anita bryant yeah started be
let's be civil with and was an anti-gay
movement now we haven't
about to give gays the right open
housing in
the biggest attacked on that vote
was the blacks they were in ninety-eight
percent against it
against a bill would've given gays
complete rights in Miami
and the reason was they said don't put
us in the gay rights category
we we have a color right-winger we're
not
gays thats completely change
gay is a civil rights issue and what the
the people opposed to have two phases
it's a losing war
Bryant you done Cody so he went to the
politicians then because these people if
they want one thing it's to remain in
power rate Matt the part that I don't
see it change
I saw george wallace yeah go from
barring the door at the University of
Alabama
not letting a student enter to his chief
of staff
being blacked yeah I sorta
I I lived in this when I arrived in
Miami
to break into broadcasting got off the
train and the first thing I saw
was a water problem is a color only and
I drank a lot from
was good war then another bus to go over
to miami Beach since they were my uncle
nice and the bike tour bus and the bus
driver pulled over and said you have to
move the front
was the bike tour bus for negroes and
the from the buses for whites
I could believe that I was for Brooklyn
there so I said
my father's black I known
was in the middle where we really have
segregation be
the other stupidity of it but I room in
Miami
a progressive city in 1957
blacks and whites couldn't compete
against each other on the football field
yeah cannot grow now missus
all these teams out the entire
mississippi best four teams black
yeah Alabama best fucking what caracal
yeah
knows sources yeah he was so now we've
seen medically we have a black president
yes we'll have a gay president yes we'll
have a female person
life this change and the politician will
have to change along with it
or blues right will you give me a
perfect segue into a little let's do a
little bit
love political footballing 226 teens
coming we talked a little bit about it
on your show
hilary is i mean is it a foregone
conclusion as much I I know he wants to
choose a nominee I don't think any I
don't think by more run against her
I think up with the promise that he'll
be secretary state I think that's
logical to think that he would be be
great sixty
to what do you make of the idea that we
have these families then you know that
it would be the bush on the closures
totally oppose
against yeah probably has one job to run
the a
general she says I love barbara Bush one
of my favorite people
ultimate stop with this forever yeah
stop with the bushes and the time stop
yeah
we've had enough but isn't that how most
american feels I think that we're sorta
being this is just being pushed on us
again like oh now chairman
and now Hillary and then it's gonna be
Maleah 2024 in Chelsea
20-30 years which those to you know you
know want
Americans like it and you know why
Americans like it
because John Kennedy said it best
what Americans really want is a kind
king
that is leave us all the now could do
that as the adams is
or the bushes or john kennedy with
the kennedys Robert would have been
president
right ted if he had maybe town didn't
have chappaquiddick human
we'd like that its as in something
inside of us likes the fact
that we have this family protector
it's a god-like thing there are
protectors you know and it seems sorta
backwards though to have our country was
born because we left England begins
yeah so what do you think that there's
about ghost I think and he had a right
we would like to crime King winners
know this is a make just bombard your
sleep norse don't rose in jail for a
crime he didn't commit
yeah don't prevent us from doing things
we want to do but please be nice
yeah just be nice don't and up citizens
off to war we're going to get killed
unless he can really just servants
be nice kind king kind caring